parfois quand on commence des recherches
sur un personnage dont la vie nous
semble particulièrement intéressante
hors du commun
on trouve une autre couche de génial
itude derrière et peep encore une autre
et tout ça nous amène un autre gentes
dames badass du jour mary wollstonecraft
né le 27 avril 1759 près de londres
elle bascule d'une famille aisée à la
ruine à cause des mauvais placements de
son père qui est en plus un homme
alcoolique et violent
à 19 ans elle quitte sa famille pour
devenir demoiselle de compagnie d'une
veuve ambal qui lui rend pas la vie plus
facile
elle rentre à londres en 1780 pour
assister sa mère dans ses derniers
moments
puis elle se cherche un peu tout en
vivant chez les blogs une famille à
laquelle elle est très attachée
elle fonde une école avec la fille de la
famille fanny mais cette belle époque se
termine en 1785 à la mort de fanni elle
devient alors gouvernance en irlande
dans une famille qui est pas plus sympa
que les précédentes et ce à partir de
cette expérience qu'elle décide de tout
envoyer bouler et de devenir écrivain
ça faisait un moment déjà que marie
construisez et affirmer ses opinions sur
la société de par ses études et de par
ses lectures quand elle vivait chez les
blogs elle est particulièrement engagé
sur la question des conditions féminines
de l'époque en décrivant la situation
malheureuse des personnes de sexe
féminin ayant reçu une bonne éducation
et laisser son fortune elle retourne
vivre à londres
elle apprend le français et l'allemand
est au début avait surtout de traduction
et de critique littéraire être prise
pour une femme
au xviiie siècle c'est pas très facile
elle fréquente des philosophes et des
personnages importants de la littérature
de l'époque comme joseph johnson qui est
son éditeur et qui devient pour elle une
sorte de mentor elle publie pensée sur
l'éducation des filles qui encore assez
peu engagés est également un recueil de
contes tu es aussi portant sur la
question de l'éducation des enfants
sa notoriété grandit en 1792 avec la
publication de défense des droits des
femmes
un ouvrage qui soutient l'éducation des
femmes il est rédigé en réponse à
plusieurs écrits conservateurs dont le
rapport talleyrand de 1791 qui affirmait
que les femmes ne devraient recevoir une
éducation à caractère domestique
c'est cet écrit qui lui vaut d'être
parfois décrite comme la première
féministe anglaise
même si le terme est un peu anachronique
pour l'époque elle critique l'idée que
les femmes serait inapte à étudier parce
qu'elles sont trop souvent guidés par
leurs émotions
ces pauvres petites choses pour voir de
plus près les événements qui en france
ont inspiré ses écrits et aussi à cause
d'une déception amoureuse
elle décide de s'installer à paris en
pleine révolution là elle rencontre un
aventurier américain gilbert immelé dont
elle a une fille en 1794 à la même date
à la couche aussi d'un nouveau roman
rist record helmand un view hand
frenchrevolution mais à cause des
événements et de la tension qui règne à
cette époque elle est finalement forcé
de rentrer en angleterre
à partir de là elle se fait aussi
appeler mi6 himmler même si gilbert et
elles ne se sont jamais mariés et qui se
séparent peu après mais tout ça c'est
pour légitimer sa fille fanny sa rupture
est très dur pour elle et renforce un
état dépressif dont elle souffre
probablement toute sa vie et donc si
vous êtes vous-même dépressif on va
aborder un sujet qui est très sensible
et pagaie et donc vous pouvez zapper à
ce time code ici là il est apparu elle
fait une tentative de suicide
puis toujours dans l'idée de récupérer
et mener éventuellement elle part en
scandinavie pour des affaires qui
pourraient l'aider financièrement elle
publie son plus gros succès lettre
écrite en suède en norvège et au
danemark
à partir de ce voyage mais à son retour
et constatant que sa relation avec
cumulée est définitivement terminée elle
décide de tenter de se suicider à
nouveau en se jetant dans la tamise et
elle est sauvée par un inconnu
la seule chose que je doive déplorer
c'est que alors que l'amertume de la
mort était déjà derrière moi j'ai été
inhumé demain ramené à la vie et à la
souffrance mais une ferme détermination
ne doit pas être troublé par la
déception et je ne permettrai pas non
plus que mon acte soit considérée comme
une tentative hystérique
car il s'est agi d'un acte de raisons
décidé dans le plus grand calme sur ce
point je n'ai de compte à rendre qu'à
moi même si je me souciais de ce qu'on
nomme la réputation ce serait pour
d'autres choses que celle là que je
mériterai le déshonneur elle revient
néanmoins dans le cercle littéraire dont
elle faisait partie avant son séjour en
france
elle se rapproche de plus en plus de
william godwin un philosophe réputé et
précurseur des pensée anarchiste
elle tombe enceinte ils décident de se
marier pour légitimer cette enfant mais
ça révèle qu'elle n'avait jamais été
marié avait cumulé est donc hyper de
passage quelques uns de leurs amis les
plus conservateurs mais ils sont heureux
ils s'installent dans deux maisons côte
à côte et il apprécie cette vie où
chacun garde une grande part de liberté
malheureusement mairie accouche de sa
fille mais
également le 30 août 1790 est elle meurt
de fièvre des suites de l'accouchement
des jours plus tard son histoire
cependant ne s'arrête pas à cette vie
intense mais brève goodwin qui passe le
reste de sa vie à entretenir la mémoire
de sa femme
publié en 1798 mémoire ou des auteurs
beaucoup de lecteurs sont choqués par sa
libéralités sa fille illégitime
ces liaisons amoureuses et ses
tentatives de suicide qui était jusqu
alors inconnu du grand public à cause de
ça sa réputation est foutu en l'air
jusqu'à la fin du 19e siècle et ses
écrits sont très peu lu elle commence à
être réhabilité parmi les scènes fawcett
le suffrage est très influente que vous
devez connaître et qui rédige
l'introduction de la reddition de 1892
de la défense des droits des femmes
elle occupe maintenant sa juste place
dans l'histoire du féminisme blâmer pour
sa vie décousue à l'écart des
conventions sociales
sa mémoire s'allier alors même que son
mari tentait de la passer à la postérité
mary wollstonecraft a pourtant laissé
des écrits important sur l'éducation
féminine qui continue de nous inspirer
endoctrinés dès leur enfance à croire
que la beauté et le sceptre de la femme
leur esprit prend la forme de leur corps
est enfermé dans cette cage dorée ne
cherche qu'à décorer sa prison elle
critique aussi le mariage en tant
qu'institution patriarcale notamment
dans ses romans
ce qui lui vaut à elle ainsi qu'à
goodwin d'être critiqués quand ils
décident eux mêmes de se marier
choisir de ne pas se marier lui aurait
fait courir le risque de perdre une
bonne partie de ces relations
comme lorsqu'on apprend qu'elle n'avait
pas épouser mais cette incitation aux
bonnes moeurs reste en vigueur pendant
très longtemps et nous la retrouverons
dans le prochain jean todt i'm bad ass
qui viendra très bientôt
quand je vous disais en début de vidéo
qu'il arrive qu'on découvre la
complexité d'un personnage couche après
couche je ne parlais pas de mouse and
craft j'ai beaucoup aimé l'étudier et
découvrir ses idées que je tenais à
partager avec vous mais je les
découvertes en faisant des recherches
sur l'autre mérite de cette histoire
mary wollstonecraft goodwin sa fille qui
devient par la suite mary shelley après
une histoire tout aussi mouvementée que
celle de sa mère dans le prochain gentes
dames badass on parlera donc pub de mary
shelley et de la création de
frankenstein
[Musique]